the Joe Rogan experience I didn't want a
fanboy out when I met you but I'm a huge
fan just like you know I really love you
music I think Dave Cross is the first
guy who turned me on to you I think yeah
I remember how I might just remember him
tell me about ex island guy bill do you
mean mister showed yeah yeah he's one he
was a big mister show was in my happiest
touring iteration like that was what we
watched every night after the show we'd
hit the bus and everyone would watch mr.
show totally passed out that's a genius
show I think it's like for Bob and Bob
did great on better call Saul and
Breaking Bad he's done a lot of other
stuff that's awesome too but there's a
something about the two of those guys
together a very unusual combination and
their writing is just so bizarre and
weird but they did a Netflix thing for a
while I don't know if there are they
still doing that do you know he's doing
those other shows no I don't think so
too bad anyway Dave Cross introduced me
to Liz Phair well I am that's a nice
that's a nice touchstone since it was
part of my touring life there you go I
feel very good about that so you got
what do you have now you have a box set
out yes it's a reissue of my first
record exile and guy though um with the
original girly sound tapes that I made
on a four track in God late 80s early
90s was that when you were living at
home yeah that was when I was recalled
back from San Francisco having not
gotten a job and run out of money and
grifted my way across like the Bay Area
I mean I had a place we we I was rooming
everyone from my college class moved out
to San Francisco basically from Oberlin
I went to and I made these little
cassettes that I forwarded to two
friends and one of them got super busy
making copies of these cassettes and
sent them to every fanzine in America
with this like glowing recommendation
and all of a sudden I was getting I was
living at home still didn't have a job
and I would get these envelopes coming
to me saying like please make me a
cassette
copy here's $10 and can you imagine what
happened to the $10 how awful is that I
truly just like I was like yeah like
there's about like a hundred people that
didn't answer Cosette but I wasn't
making the cassettes but anyway that's
sort of Taiwan U is actually the person
who made lots of cassettes and sent them
around so I want him to think did you
have a thought that you were going to
eventually make it or be a big singer
the dude was that even an idea not a
clue I created being in front of people
like I would not want to I loved being
in the studio I loved recording but I
didn't I was super stage frightened and
I couldn't think of anything I'd rather
do less than get up in front of you play
music or do anything really yeah
absolutely
Wow but it was hard but you obviously
have a love of music I love playing
music I just I get very self-conscious
with it you gotta pull this sucker up to
you otherwise we're not gonna I get very
self-conscious in front of crowd still
not so much anymore I do about two weeks
before I hit the stage I will stop
sleeping and then really ya know work
myself into this kind of cold sweat when
I think about it like can I leave the
country and then like I get on the stage
and it all comes back to me and I'm like
I've done this a million times this is
the best job in the world and just I
can't psych myself into that feeling
until I'm actually on stage maybe that's
just cuz you care about it so much
probably I'm too alert we should be
smoking those joints that are not which
I'm had I have some over here I know
can't even imagine where we'd go with
that we do it all let me know we're
about 10 minutes in you change your mind
it's really rough it gets really
personal maybe oh yeah sometimes you
have to just I'm a very awake person hmm
well that's a good thing
[Applause]